mériadec raffray journaliste spécialiste
des questions de défense mais rien avec
raterait bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors ankara qui
annonce donc que la turquie et la grèce
étaient prêtes à entamer des pourparlers
sur leur différend et puis cet appel
téléphonique entre red chez hyper doan
emmanuel macron est ce qu'on peut parler
on peut penser à un début de détente à
écouter il est trop tôt pour le dire il
va falloir qu'on voit les effets
concrets sur le terrain entre guillemets
de ce coup de fil écoutez c'est toujours
bien de se parler est effectivement ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois la
tension entre les deux hommes était
monté presque aux extrêmes je rappelle
par exemple il ya quelques jours
erdogan fait quelques semaines art hogan
d'isère encore amoureux de macron un
ambitieux incapable bon emmanuel macron
n'a pas été sur ce registre là en
revanche cette tension entre les deux
hommes elle était également palpable en
méditerranée en particulier en
méditerranée orientale où actuellement
une quarantaine à une cinquantaine de
navires de guerre sont présents on est
un peu revenu au temps de la guerre
froide des navires turcs en nombre
important et des navires français aussi
et je vous rappelle que mi juin il ya eu
un incident inédit entre deux frégates
une française et une une turque donc la
tension était évidemment à la fois
palpable au niveau diplomatique
elle était aussi et des potentiels en
tout cas au niveau militaire
donc il va falloir voir concrètement
comment en fait le commandant diaz les
fruits de ce dialogue va se concrétiser
et pour terminer je rappelle enfin que
les contentieux sont importants
aujourd'hui entre la turquie et la
france et de d'ordre très différents
alors vous rappeliez les tensions très
vives entre emmanuel macron est chez
hyper douanes ces dernières semaines à
l'initiative de cet appel vient du
président français
une initiative acceptée par le président
du rck est ce que c'est un bon signe
tout de même
oui bien sûr certains disaient dans
l'entourage du président français qu'il
était pardonnez moi l'expression
remonté comme un coucou contraire dogan
jeu mais c'est entre guillemets je veux
dire qu'il était il faisait il ne
cachait pas en fait son agacement
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis d'erdogan et de la
latitude
enfin évidemment de ses déclarations
mais également de les faits et gestes de
la turquie dans une zone d'influencé que
se partagent les turcs aujourd'hui et la
france je veux bien sûr parler de la
méditerranée donc voilà donc les les
militaires disent est du côté français
que les canaux de discussions de
dialogue habituel et est ouvert que les
chaînes de commandement et les chaînes
de commandement national était robuste
mais qu' évidemment dans cette situation
un peu comme du temps de la guerre
froide où les bâtiments de guerre se
côtoient vous savez pour un bâtiment
guerre en fait l'espace se réduit
considérablement
donc dans cet espace à peu réduit
aujourd'hui plusieurs de nombreux
bâtiments de guerre se côtoient un ainsi
noah toujours probable et dans ce cadre
là comment dirais-je une erreur humaine
d'appréciation peut conduire à mettre
une presse sur un brasier en fait qui ne
demande qu'à éclater voyez donc de ce
point de vue là évidemment la diplôme
que la diplomatie retrouve ses droits
ça me parait de photos de bonne augure
alors pourquoi comment est ce qu'on peut
comprendre que le climat temps à
s'apaiser
maintenant qu'est-ce qui a changé
précisément écoutez je vais avoir en
tout état de cause qui est clair c'est
que la france a envoyé un ou deux
signaux forts importants notamment par
exemple en mettant sur le la table de
l'otan l'incident qui a eu lieu en jean
à mi juin
mi juin dernier entre les deux bâtiments
de guerre français et turcs
les autorités françaises disent qu'elles
ont envoyé un signal aux autorités
turques que celui-ci distel a priori a
été reçu cinq sur cinq
on peut également évoquer le l'annnonce
du contrat de rafale vendus donc par la
france en tout cas sur le point d'être
vendus par la france à la lame à l'armée
grecque
c est également aussi un signal un
symbole de force et talent cela
donnerait à la grèce un potentiel
militaire qu'elle n'a pas aujourd'hui là
bien sûr des avions mirage français mais
qui n'ont pas la capacité et la qui ne
sont pas si moderne que des rafales
donc voilà au mois deux signaux forts en
fer erdogan
ceci dit pour pour équilibrer les choses
il faut rappeler que erdogan n'est pas
quelqu'un que l'on pût eux que l'on peut
intimider facilement c'est quelqu'un qui
comprend la force il déploie une
stratégie pragmatique qui a la sienne
qu'on peut critiquer ou pas c'est une
stratégie impériale nationaliste qui est
historique qui a des bases historiques
qui se déploient notamment vers l'ouest
et et vers le sud
cette ministre ait stratégie qu'on
qualifie de néo ottomane c'est quelqu'un
qui comprend la loi de la force comme
dans les relations internationales
il a eu un contentieux vif contentieux
avec les américains il a un vif
contentieux avec les russes de puissance
par ailleurs avec laquelle erdogan
travail discutent et négocie donc voilà
donc en fait erdogan comprend la force
et les spécialistes qualifiés
la réaction de la france suite à ses
dernières incidents en méditerranée de
symbolique c'est à dire que la france
n'a pas été très comment dire lg le très
agressif dans la réaction
dans sa réaction face à l'agressivité
pour les coûts de la turquie merci
beaucoup mériadec raffray d'avoir
partagé votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste de
défense